It's great to welcome to the program today,
Timothy Morton, who's an ecological philosopher
at rice university, also
author of the book being ecological out with
penguin and MIT.
It's so great to have you on today.
Oh, thank you so much for having me.
It's an honor and if I couldn't do things
like this, I couldn't think you have to sort
of work with other people to be able to do
that.
If you're, if you're me, let's
do it.
I mean, I think maybe to start, let's define
some terms a little bit.
I think that maybe the term ecology and ecological
is not often understood by many.
There's sort of something in there that relates
to the environment.
There's something in there that relates to
climate change or maybe not.
So can we maybe start with defining what the
field is and what we're talking about?
Well, the funny thing is that the word ecology
is like the word economy.
And we sort of know what economy means.
Um, economy means like how you organize your
house actually that first two syllables, the
eco bit means house in Greek, you know, incoming,
outgoing flows of money and whatever.
And roughly it's, it's sort of to do how you
organize your enjoyment, right?
You know, like I'll give you 50 cents and
you give me this ice cream as a free cheap
ice cream for some reason.
Um, ecology is in a way the logic of that.
It's the logic of where we live.
Um, how it, how it works.
And the funny thing is of course, is that
classical economic theory doesn't seem to
have anything to do very much with coral or
mountains or whatever.
But I guess we're finding out right now just
how connected these things are.
Um, that actually by ignoring, um, some of
the things like coral and mountains, um, we
might have, uh, got some things a bit screwy
with, with our, with our economics, with our
way of doing it.
So
what would be some examples of maybe the questions
that would be the questions that the field
considers?
Oh, well, um, one very strong question would
be, uh, at what scales is this thing happening?
Right?
Like in a funny way, ecological awareness
just means being aware that things are happening
on more than one scale at once.
So for example, you start your car now that's
actually, you know, on a planet scale, statistically
meaningless, you haven't done anything, you
shouldn't feel built guilty in a way.
Um, I like to say that maybe there's a difference
between guilty and responsible.
Um, then billions and billions of those are
doing something.
So there's a funny paradox, which is that
on one scale, nothing's happening.
On another scale, everything is, is happening
and it's the same thing.
You're doing the same thing.
So in the, in the field of, you know, climate
change and environmentalism, one debate that
exists that I think is, uh, is a better one
than does it exist.
I think that that's not a good debate at this
point.
But one is personal responsibility versus
corporate responsibility.
So the discussion of plastic straws and getting
a car with slightly better gas mileage or
whatever the case may be.
And a counter to the entire framing of those
questions is that this is not really about
the decisions of the individual because the
overwhelming, I think it's, you know, 70%
of emissions come from just a hundred companies
or something like that, so that the conversation
is actually happening at the wrong scale within
the ecological framework.
As you say, you know, there's the little action
and things are happening on, on multiple layers.
Is there a particular level of zooms, so to
speak, that is the predominant one in the
questions you deal with?
Oh, well, um, you're quite right to suggest,
I feel that the, um, individual scale is a
bit too small and it also brings up questions
of good and evil.
Like, am I doing this right?
You know, what's the right shampoo to choose?
I've got 200 shampoos in the shop and I'm
confronted with them like this giant ice flow
and it's made of shampoo and I have to figure
out which one to do and it's quite alien,
you know?
Um, and um, of course there's a, there's an
awful feeling of powerlessness when you're
thinking about something happening at planet
scale.
And I'm old enough to remember those things
in the 90s where in the media sometimes people
would say things like, if we just did this
one thing like save toilet paper or jump up
and down on the spot for awhile, then this
would happen.
If we just did it for two weeks, then this
other amazing thing would happen.
And it's as if the onus is put on, on us as
individuals.
And I, I like to distinguish between guilty
and responsible.
I'm, I'm doing this interview across from
Chevron and all those companies cause I work
at rice university and in Houston and it's
quite clear who's guilty in a way.
Like some people knew that global warming
was happening and that uh, and so forth quite
a long time ago.
Um, rather like the cigarettes situation,
on the other hand, everyone's responsible
and it doesn't mean that even that you have
to prove that you did it or do you have to
prove is that you can understand it, right?
Like if you see somebody running in the street
and they're going to get hit by a car, you're
responsible for that person and you don't
have to prove even that you did it.
Um, and even maybe it might waste some time.
You know, you might be trying to prove that
you did it, the calculator and suddenly the
person got hit anyway.
So in a funny way, I feel like taking a lot
of that guilt of the people's shoulders and
I feel like people like me often make ordinary
people feel stupid and evil and, and that's
probably why our message isn't working so
great.
What is it that when it comes to solving the
problems that we're dealing with, you see
as the biggest impediment because it's very
easy and I think at least partially accurate
to say that there are significant corporate
interests that stand to lose a lot of money
if we actually start dealing seriously with
the problems that we're having.
But that I think is only one piece of it.
So are there others, you know, there's this
idea of analysis paralysis of endlessly seeking
facts without a path forward.
I'll just open it.
What else is preventing us from solving this?
Well, the way that we talk to each other about
it is quite inhibiting.
Um, I'm sometimes like to think that it's
not exactly how, what you think that's could
start world war four or whatever, but, but,
but how you think?
Yeah.
Like there are different ideas, for example,
about what the word belief means, you know,
disbelief.
I mean, hold on really, really tight or something.
I never let go.
Or disbelieve means something more like trusting,
you know, just sort of allowing things to,
to, to be the case.
And, um, so you know, in a way it, it's to
do with what we think all these deep things
about what does believe mean, what does responsible
mean?
And in general, how do we act in groups?
You know, I mean we're, we, we on our daily
lives, we are members of lots and lots of
overlapping intersecting different sizes of
group.
And if we're going to work with this global
warming stuff, it's a 7.5 billion group problem.
And, and that's a big challenge actually to
imagine ourselves as part of a group without
thinking that the group is like this glass
of water in which we just dissolve like salt
or sugar and we don't really mean anything
and we don't really exist.
And it's a tremendously inhibiting to think,
you know, and again, perhaps it's a hangover
from not, not so great aspects of some religion
that's feeling like you're part of something
bigger.
It makes you feel like you don't count.
Yeah.
I, I in uh, of his book, guns, germs and steel,
Jared diamond talks quite a bit about the
size of groups in which humans can function
in different ways.
And to different degrees.
And it seems that when we're talking about
ecology, we, we really are talking about the
planet.
I mean everybody is part of it in a sense.
And that seems overwhelming to some degree.
Is this the role?
Is this why we have governments?
I mean, I don't, I don't want to be pessimistic
and maybe you're not pessimistic, but how
do we wrap our mind around how to solve a
problem of that scope and size?
I have awful trouble with, with, um, dangle
two feelings about this.
So I, I feel badly a lot.
Um, so one of my favorite hobbies is feeling
badly.
And, um, I feel like if I'm just lying there
in the fetal position, you know, on the floor,
which is how I feel sometimes when I hear
this data, there's nothing I can do about
it, you know?
So I have to figure out how to scrape myself
off the floor and get up and do something.
So one has to feel somewhat confident in the
face of the, the, the awfulness.
Um, I think really that, um, what we're dealing
with is, uh, obviously a, again, it's a, it's
a problem to do with, um, knowing that the,
that what you do at one scale might suck at
another scale, right?
Like, like very crudely.
Um, nothing that everything's sort of interconnected
on the planet means that if you're going to
be nice to bunny rabbits, it means that you're
not going to be nice to bunny rabbit parasites.
So part of it is this Groundhog day situation.
If you remember the film Groundhog day, bill
Murray tries to get it right.
It keeps going through the same day over and
over again when he realizes he can never ever
save the guy who's going to get hit.
And that's a little bit like ecological awareness.
There's always going to be some flaw in your
plan, but that doesn't mean you should, you
should not try to carry it out.
And so part of it is, you know, realizing
that we're always going to feel a little bit
like Hippocrates and Murray's going to wonder
exactly why we're doing what we're doing.
They're on point enough reasons all the time.
When it comes to action, I mean, is there,
do you think on those terms, is there, when
we look at fossil fuels, trash, plastics,
the oceans, the ozone, all of these different,
is there even something that you would say
should be the areas of focus at this point?
Oh, well actually it's very easy for an individual
person, um, to realize that actually the best
thing you can do as an individual is to eat
a little bit less than need.
If you're wondering what to do right now and
you're feeling overwhelmed by all of this.
And the way we talk to each other about it
is so triggering and sort of PTSD, and you
open the paper and it says that, you know,
500 to 16%, 20,000 years and it's also confusing.
And then there's another lot of data dumped
on either the next day, you know?
Um, and then you read the editorial section
and it's like, Oh, you're really evil.
You're bad.
You know?
And so no wonder people feel put off, but
actually there's something very simple you
can do.
While we're waiting for people to do bigger
things, um, which is each a little bit less
meat.
It's amazing how much fossil fuel emissions
there are in agriculture.
And if you want to do something right now,
I would seriously advise, I would seriously
advise that as you've got a car and if you
do and it's probably quite expensive to pay
it off.
Maybe it's better just to focus on the food
right now and not worry so much about about
the car aspect.
That's interesting.
And that's something I try to do and, and
I advocate for and yet if I recall correctly,
I think agricultural emissions or something
like 13% of total emissions.
So we sort of are back in this position of
even if we all did it, we're dealing with
maybe a 10th of the problem.
And I is, that may be what gets some people
to do nothing instead.
I think so, yes, there's a feeling of paralysis
and you know, I guess one of the most important
things in the short term is to remember to
vote, you know, figure out who can represent
you, who can work some things out, um, politically
in, in, in larger groups.
Um, it's, it's probably more effective than
anything.
I think right now, even though some things
may seem more, um, to seem seemingly direct
and sort of more obvious or flamboyant, um,
for regular folks folks, I think just figuring
out who's the right person to vote for with
all of this is probably the best.
It's probably the best tactic right now
in thinking a little more broadly, like maybe
five years, 10 years, 20 years are individual
conversations where you try to convince someone
who simply doesn't believe that we are affecting
the climate and our planet.
Is that a worthwhile conversation to have
or are those sort of vestigial remains so
to speak, that will eventually go away?
And that's not really where our focus should
be arguing with people about whether it's
real.
Gosh, that's interesting.
Um, well, you know, the funny thing is that,
you know, the wondering whether it's real
or not, is it a funny way, a symptom of the
fact that it's real?
I don't know if either there've been in a
car accident but, but, but, but when you're
in something like that, some kind of traumatic
situation, the thought is, gosh, is this really
happening?
And all around the world people are going,
is this actually for real, this global warming
mass extinction thing?
And that's actually a signal that it is happening
in a funny, in a funny way.
Another thing to say about this is that, um,
that kind of conversation where you try to
convince someone, yeah, probably that kind
of conversation has hoovered up as many people
as it possibly can now who want to believe
this stuff.
I think it's probably more effective to have
other kinds of conversation that don't necessarily
obviously direct, like for example, have a
conversation about responsibility.
You know, like again, maybe jellyfish did
this, but because I can understand it, I can
responsible for it, right?
And because I've got fingers that can switch
off the keyboard switches that switch off
the oil pipes, I need to do this because dolphins
can't do it cause they flip.
It's con like what the keyboards.
That's it.
So, but I mean, so, so the, the idea and thinking
pragmatically then is that although there's
nothing wrong necessarily with trying to convince
people, but that has been going on for so
long that the convincible people likely already
have been, am I sort of understanding what
you're saying?
Yes, yes, exactly.
Exactly.
Is I, I feel like, you know, I, I was in the
local burger place.
I live in Texas and so water burger is our
Texas burger place.
We're all very proud of it.
And, um, I just seen an incredible retired
by the adults are doing this incredible performance
of this Debussy ballet in Paris.
And then the person who served me, the sources
cause as, suppose someone comes with a tray
with the sources or this place came to the
table to serve this.
I thought, gosh, your, you are handling yourself
as gracefully as this ballet dancer person
in Paris.
And you know, people like me make people like
you feel stupid and evil most of the time.
No wonder we haven't started fixing this thing.
Like, I mean, obviously there's other things
to blame, but who can I blame?
But myself if the situation isn't, isn't going
so great.
Any situation.
Right.
I don't know if you've seen the democratic
presidential debates that have taken place
so far, but if you have, I'd be curious to
know what is your assessment of the way in
which these issues are discussed, whether
it's climate, a fossil fuels, energy, whatever.
I mean in terms of the questions that are
asked as sort of part a and in terms of the,
the framing of the answers as well.
Gosh, that's very, very deep and it's very,
very important because I've been, okay, I
feel like how you do a thing is the thing
in a way.
Um, it's not an optional extra how we ask
ourselves questions about this and how we
talk about it.
And it seems to me that the way it's talked
about quite often, um, is, you know, perhaps
some of the solutions are right, but, um,
th the language is very chained to cratic
and it's not very democratically empowering
and it's not scaled so that you don't think
like, what can I do as, as someone in my neighborhood,
right?
Like what can I do with someone in mine who
lives in a street all lives in a town?
Of course they need to, to be trans state
international action on all of this stuff.
Um, and, and yet at the same time, I think
the way we talk about it, it makes it seem
like this scary alien thing.
And it is scary, but it better not be alien
because if it's alien and it's just something
that happens, like fate or destiny or nature
or whatever the old word nature that I do,
that things just sort of happen without your
will, you know?
And this is something that we have to input
our will into.
So the way that you talk about it as a little
bit stifling, I fail.
That's a very good question.
What would be an example of a question that
you would like to hear from moderators pose
to the candidates that would maybe be more
encompassing or framed in a, in a better way?
Hmm.
Um, how do you think neighborhoods and local
communities can organize to affect ecological
political change would be my number one question.
Just to get people in the mindset of thinking
this is a thing we can do.
You know, like we all live in a neighborhood
and in a funny way, the neighborhood is sort
of a very good unit of political change.
It's not the individuals, it's, it's a group,
but it's small enough and it's connected enough
to your actual physical location and what,
who you are and who you know that it's, it's,
it, it, it's got this reality to it.
That's interesting.
I mean, just, I'm imagining it being asked
and I just know that the candidates, at least
that we currently have would, if you're lucky,
give an answer that is even tangentially related.
I mean is, you know, that's one of the things
where one of the critiques I've had of the
debates is that the format doesn't really
allow for depth.
But the other issue is that on a lot of these
issues, the candidates don't really know more
than two or three talking points related to
the issue.
And that that just seems like more of a, I
mean, it just, this is not an area of expertise
really for any of the candidates I think unless
you, you think there's someone who is better
on this issue.
Yeah, no, I, I, I think, you know, obviously
someone like Bernie Sanders has got the right
idea of the scale of, of, of, of funding involved
to make this problem go away.
But um, again, it's, it's sort of about owning
this as an issue.
When you read the paper, it's almost as if
we are continually surprised.
For example, unbolted hurricanes affect poor
people and black people, for example, worse
than white people or well off people.
And you sort of think to yourself, gosh, you
know what?
What else in social space do we treat like
this?
It's as if the hurricane is coming way, way
from the, from the outside of our knowledge.
And it's like shock, horror, bad thing affects
poor suffering people worse.
And it's like, well, what doesn't do that?
We should be owning this right now.
And sort of figuring out how to become more
familiar with it.
Otherwise it's just this huge daunting mountain
of, of data that we're looking at like free
tout romantic poets or something.
Yeah.
I mean your book being ecological is not about
beating people over the head with facts, but
how would you, how would you sort of summarize
the effect you would hope the book would have
on someone who reads it?
Oh, um, well I got asked by penguin to write
this book and I thought, gosh, penguin, you've
confirmed me a golden microphone to talk to
people.
And I'm a scholar.
I don't get out much when I go to talk to
people.
So it's like, what to wait?
How can I use this opportunity?
Right?
I know people like me say, you know, we, we
have this horrible phrase, what does it to
appeal to a wider audience that's so condescending?
You know, I personally think that th that
making a nice thing for lots of people to
read is off the level in a way from being
right in that heavy duty, medieval way that
happens in universities.
I'm making it kind of rubber stamping motion
with my hand, cause that's how it sort of
works.
Um, whereas, you know, um, being interesting,
you know, is there's a philosopher called
Heraclitis, he's an ancient Greek philosopher
and he said something very beautiful.
I love very much.
He says, the truth cannot be directly stated.
You have to evoke it.
Right?
And all this direct stating and pointing and
this is bad and you're a bad person.
It's just not, I mean, I'm quite a defined
person.
So if I hear this kind of thing, I mean to
myself, I tend to consistent pretty strongly.
Um, so my sense of the project is just basically
trying to very gently evoke things, which
ends up becoming more powerful actually than,
than yelling.
Um, there's a very good phrase I heard once
about the novelist Marcel Proust by one of
my favorite.
So lots of those actually Geico, Theodore
Adorno, the German philosopher, and he says
something very beautiful, which you could
also think about Jane Austin if you've never
read Bruce, do you say?
So?
[inaudible] Preuss destroys the aristocracy
with remorseless gentleness.
That's the phrase that he uses.
And I like this idea of, of, of gentleness
can be more effective.
Um, then aggression, you think about the nonviolent
direct action things that have happened, Martin
Luther King and so on.
And you sort of see the point of that.
I'm going to phrase this last question and
what maybe is not ripe for an academic answer,
but if zero is total pessimism and 10 is total,
uh, optimism about figuring this out before
we destroy ourselves, where are you?
Uh, well, um, two and a half, two years for
ambiguity.
Um, because on the one hand, um, as far as
understanding this issue goes, I'm at a one
or a zero, you know, pessimism of the intellect
as they say.
Um, as far as failing, like we've got this
actually, if we can do this, so just stay
to a little tiny adjustment and to get into
doing this.
Um, I'm at a nine or return actually.
So it's very ambiguous for me.
Um, pessimism of the intellect, optimism of
the will.
That's why that's my slogan.
So the answer is depending on where are you
from, zero to 10, it, the, the, the answer
is it depends from where you are measuring
in some sense.
Yeah, it's hard.
The zero will turn is a don't mess with Mister
in between.
That's what I say.
We've been speaking with Timothy Morton who's
an ecological philosopher at rice university.
The book is being ecological Timothy, so great
having you on today.
So thank you much.
It's been a pleasure.